>> Jesse: WITH GREAT POWER COMES
GREAT RESPONSIBILITY.
HOW YOU HANDLE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY SAYS EVERYTHING
ABOUT YOUR SKILL SET AS
A LEADER.
AT LEAST 13 OF OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS WERE KILLED IN
YESTERDAY'S TERRORISTS ATTACKS
ON THE AIRPORT.
WHILE HUNDREDS OF DESPERATE
AMERICANS ARE TRYING TO FLEE
AFGHANISTAN.
OUR COMMANDER IN CHIEF SAYS HE
TAKES FULL RESPONSIBILITY BUT
NOT REALLY.
TIME TO BLAME TRUMP.
>> I BEAR RESPONSIBILITY FOR
FUNDAMENTALLY ALL THAT'S
HAPPENED OF LATE.
HERE'S THE DEAL:
YOU N
KNOW AS WELL
THE FORMER PRESIDENT MADE A DEAL
WITH THE TALIBAN TO GET ALL
AMERICAN FORCES OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN BY MAY 1.
>> Jesse: POINTINGS THE FINGER
AT SOMEONE ELSE IS SOMETHING
DEMOCRATS DO WELL.
NOBODY CAN DO IT BETTER THAN
HILLARY CLINTON.
REMEMBER HERE?
>> AS I SAID MANY TIMES SINCE
SEPTEMBER 11th I TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
WHEN I TOOK RESPONSIBILITY I
TOOK IT AS A CHALLENGE.
I TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
>> YOU HAVE NOT PUT THE BLAME ON
YOURSELF.
HILLARY TRIES TO BLAME OTHER
PEOPLE.
DO YOU ACCEPT THAT CRITICISM?
>> NO, I DON'T.
>> Jesse: HERE'S SOMEONE WHO
KNOWS WHAT IT'S TO BE A LEADER.
VETERAN NAVY SEAL AND AN AUTHOR.
WHEN YOU HEAR THEM TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY AND SAY THE WORD
BUT, NO, THAT'S A RED FLAG.
WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE LIKED THE
PRESIDENT TO HAVE SAID THIS
WEEK?
>> WELL, AS YOU JUST POINTED
OUT, WHEN YOU TAKE OWNERSHIP OF
SOMETHING YOU CAN'T FOLLOW IT
WITH THE WORD BUT ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND YOU ARE
LITERALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
AND PUT A PLAN INTO ACTION TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN
CREATED BY YOU.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO SEE FROM
THE PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
>> Jesse: HIS METHOD IS EMPATHY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SAY I FEEL
YOUR PAIN AND EVEN THOUGH I
CAUSED THAT PAIN, THAT'S GOING
TO ABSOLVE ME OF ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR IT.
THAT SEEMS TO FLY IN POLITICS.
WHEN YOU ARE THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, THE HEAD OF
THE MILITARY, I DON'T THINK THAT
CUTS IT.
>> I THINK HE IS SAYING A BUNCH
OF WORDS RIGHT NOW THAT HAVE
LESS MEANING EVERY DAY.
HE MADE A STATEMENT WE WON'T
FORGET AND WE WILL HUNT YOU DOWN
AND MAKE YOU PAY.
IN THE MEANTIME WE ARE FOLLOWING
THE ORDERS OF THE TALIBAN AND
THEY WANT US OUT OF THERE BY
AUGUST 31.
THAT'S WHEN WE ARE LEAVING.
IT DOESN'T MATCH UP.
HIS ACTIONS DON'T MATCH HIS
WORDS.
HIS WORDS ARE BECOMING MORE AND
MORE WEAK EVERY DAY.
>> Jesse: WE RAN WITH KELLOGG,
THE GUY THAT DID THE DEAL UNDER
TRUMP WITH THE TALIBAN.
HE SAID LAST NIGHT, THE DATE
COULD HAVE BEEN MOVED.
IT WAS NOT SET IN STONE.
THERE WERE 4 CONDITIONS THAT HAD
TO BE MET, AND THE TRUMP PLAN
WAS TO KEEP BAGRAM AND 2500
AMERICAN FORCES THERE AND
PARAMILITARY GUYS FROM THE CIA
THERE UNTIL EVERYBODY WAS OUT
AND ALL OF THE WEAPONS WERE OUT.
BIDEN JUST BLEW IT UP.
SET AN ARBITRARY DATE WITH NO
CONDITIONS AND IT WAS
HELTER-SKELTER.
>> WE ARE TRYING TO ATTEMPT TO
NEGOTIATION FROM WEAKNESS.
WE SHOULD NEVER DO.
WE SHOULD NEGOTIATE DOCTOR FROM
A POSITION OF STRENGTH BECAUSE
WE ARE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA WITH THE STRONGEST
MILITARY IN THE WORLD.
>> Jesse: CHECK OUT THE PODCAST
AND THE BOOK.
I READ THE BOOK.
I DON'T BLAME THE PRODUCERS FOR
ANYTHING.
I OWE I